- The performance for me makes sense
if it's live.
And doesn't make so much
sense if it's documentation.
Everything else would left over,
like photograph or video,
not the real thing.
The real thing the audience
have to be in the place
what happen and to see that.
So maybe the most
documentation, which is valuable
would be the memory of the audience
and the actual story which they
will tell to somebody else.
And somehow all the artists
in the '70s left just
documentation and not
any kind of (mumbles)
and how this actually can turn
into the kind of live process.
Because some artists
absolutely don't want to be
re-perform the pieces
because they felt that they
done it in such a beautiful
time that doesn't work later on.
Another artist and critics
will think that if there
somebody else re-perform the
piece, actually is not anymore
the piece of the artist idea.
It would be a new piece because
he add his own personality inside.
But I really think that
it's very important
to re-perform the pieces
even with all this danger
that becomes somebody else piece.
But still you have to refer
to the original source
and you can make your own version.
If today you can re-perform
Bach, and make techno Bach
out of this, why you can't
re-perform the performance?
The only way that reformists
of this live element inside.
So I have to live like that
because otherwise it's
just dead photograph
on the paper or just another video.